it's Peter white and I teaching the
mathematics department at Columbia
University or my title is senior
lecturer
yeah well first thing they say is that
when people said talk about string
theory they're actually talking about a
very complex set of ideas that lots of
people you know very large my people
have worked on and done a lot of
different things with the the probably
what it's best known for and what got
people all excited about it in the
physics community is there's kind of a
conjecture that instead of at the most
fundamental level you can understand
matter and the universe in in terms not
of point particles which is the way our
best theory is currently you kind of
understand things but in terms of kind
of vibrate if you like vibrating have
loops of some elementary objects your
elementary object instead of being a
point like thing is something you should
think of more as being a one-dimensional
loop or kind of string which is kind of
moving around so it has a lot more it
can do a lot more complicated things
than a point is this kind of loop of
elementary matter or whatever it is and
so it gives you a very different kind of
class of theories than the ones that
we've been so successful with before and
the they can J so during the sixties
that this idea was initially developed
and initially people tried to do one
thing with these class of theories
something which didn't work out that
well and then starting in the late 70s
and 80s people then came up with a
conjecture that maybe you really could
unify all of physics and solve some of
the open problems in physics by
replacing our standard theories maybe we
call the standard model with some kind
of string theory and that's so so since
this idea became very popular in 1984
and so it's been now 25 years people
have been working very hard on that and
and and I think just the initial thing
I've got people are very excited at
least I would claim you know really
hasn't worked out and really can't work
out and that's kind of been a lot of the
reason controversy has been an argument
over this issue of you know whether this
some very speculative idea about whether
you can use these strings to develop
having to get a unified theory about
whether that really has is that is that
an idea that's failed or is there still
some hope for it I think that's really
the what's the controversial part of it
well the main thing to understand about
the current state of physics is that we
have we're in some sense kind of victim
of our own success we have an incredibly
successful theory called a standard
model and it it really explains
everything that we can observe about and
in terms of a fairly small number of
elementary particles and some basic
forces between them and it's a it's a
quite beautiful theory and um it really
is just kind of absurdly successful
every experiment anybody knows how to do
that in principle can be that this
theory has something to say about it
works it works out perfectly you know to
whatever experimental in whatever detail
you can do an experiment to whatever
precision that comes out exactly as
predicted by this model so we have kind
of a semi unified theory this we have
this quite nice beautiful structure
which explains everything we can see but
if so it still leaves open several
questions and some of the questions are
just kind of why you know we have all
these different particles they all have
different masses why do they all have
different masses we don't understand why
the electron has a certain mass quartz
of other masses so so they're just kind
of things which the theory just doesn't
address it just doesn't answer these
questions and they're questions that
which has physicists we think there
should be answers to but then there's
also one kind of remaining force which
isn't part of the standard model which
is the four which is the gravitational
force and the the gravitational force is
much much weaker than these other forces
and it has somewhat different nature so
it the problem with it is that we don't
um these other forces we have something
which is a quantum theory it really it's
it's quantum mechanics it it really
works down to the microscopic level and
in terms of this very fundamental idea
about that reality called quantum
mechanics the theory of gravity that we
still use is Einstein's theory of
general relativity and it's what we call
a classical theory it's not a quantum
mechanical theory and the you can make
an estimate the problem is you can make
an estimate within this theory of how
big quantum mechanical effects would be
and that estimate tells you that they're
just so absurdly small you
never hope to see them so there's kind
of a problem of principle we had this
theory which is not a proper quantum
mechanical theory and we know that
there's things which it can't quite
properly explain but there there's
they're far too small for us to study
them and to try to see them so anyways
we're not completely happy with this set
up we have a force which doesn't quite
fit with the others and which for
logical reasons is that we would like to
unify it with these others and
understand it as a quantum mechanical
theory and we've never been successful
and able to do that and and this is what
string theory was it was kind of a
promise of a way of how to do that and
that's kind of that that's why people
got so excited
it's kind that's kind of famous phrase
among physicists it goes back to a
there's a well-known theorist called
Wolfgang Pauli in the 50s stories that
toward the end of his life someone I
guess he was well known for being very
kind of hyper critical of things that
were going on and would get up the
middle of a seminar and start saying you
know it's wrong it's completely wrong
and late in his life someone asked him
about some work some some speculative
idea of someone and given Lee shook his
head and said well that one's not even
wrong and and so the it's a well-known
phrase among physicists and it kind of
carries I think to two meanings I mean
one of them is just kind of a more or
somewhat of a term of abuse well that's
so bad it's not even wrong but but
there's a more interesting it is also
more kind of technical meaning that a
very often used to you have aspect you
have a speculative idea and if it's if
it's a lot a very good idea or it turns
out you actually can even you end up not
being able to do very much with it you
end up not being able to to predict
anything with it or - it's just not
useful so there's also a notion of not
being not even wrong in the sense that
it's not an idea which can be fully
developed or it can turn into something
which is powerful enough to actually
predict something and be wrong so this
it's a tie
one problem of string theory is that
it's kind of a theory which that can
explain what the problems are but the
problems are such that you can't ever
even pin it down and say this is exactly
what it predicts and let's go out and
test it so it's not even capable of
being wrong being wrong or being
falsified or being shown to be wrong so
that's the more relevant meaning here
really
I said I mean it's string theory is
actually a very complicated story so
they're there you know if you start out
with this hypothesis that maybe your
Fenneman objects are not points but are
these strings there's a lot of different
things you can try and do that you can
do you have a whole different class of
theories you can play with and so I
think a lot of if you look at what most
people who are still doing strengths you
are doing they're actually not directly
trying to you know to develop this
unified theory anymore they're they're
all kind of doing other things with
string theory there that people these
days are trying to apply it to to
problems and nuclear physics they're
probably applying it to problems in um
in solid state physics understand
conductors so they're the people who
still are interested in it you know are
are often kind of even if they will they
may or may not explicitly admit that
they've kind of given up on the unified
theory idea but they're they're often
doing other things so there's a there's
a very active pursuit of string theory
in you know with other applications that
don't have any dude unification it's
also turn out to be very interesting in
in mathematics there's a very one of the
things that I'm most interested in is
the intersection between mathematics and
physics and the way the two fields kind
of affect each other and ideas from
physics lead to very interesting things
in mathematics ideas in mathematics get
used and they give us new physics and
string theory has been very very
fruitful in terms of raising questions
which have a have led to very
interesting mathematics so there's a
very active field of research come in
between math and physics in string
theory but but it but it doesn't seem to
be relevant to this question of
unification
I certainly shouldn't my criticism of
string theory is not that well you know
if you guys are just realize that you
should be doing such-and-such that would
that would solve a lot of problems that
I don't actually I don't think that I
have some my own ideas which I'm very
excited about which I which I'm pursuing
which are also new ideas about how to
use mathematics to do things in physics
which don't have anything to do with
string theory and and which kind of at
least lead me to see there you know
there's a lot of areas a lot of things
we don't understand
which are closer to our the standard
model which we which we do know works
there's a lot of kind of mathematical
mathematical structure behind the
standard model which is still kind of
mysterious and which is not well
understood and I think pursuing that is
more likely to get us somewhere then the
distinct three unification idea just
because you're starting from something
which you know what a theory what you
know is right and trying to further
develop your understanding of that
theory is maybe a more fruitful thing to
do then I'm trying to you know just
going to throw out throw that throw all
that out and start afresh with something
more speculative the yum I guess is it
one thing to talk about is the this
what's happening in in Geneva even this
is this month and so the a lot of the a
lot of the problem with the field as
I've said is this business of being a
victim of our own success not having any
experimental results that disagree with
the theory which makes it very very hard
to figure out how do how do you improve
a theory if you've got no kind of clues
as to what you know what what what might
possibly be wrong that it needs to be
needs to be changed and so there's a
this accelerator called the LHC okay at
CERN in Geneva and it's been in
development for quite a few years now
and has been long process getting it
working with just over the past month
they've finally going to inject beams
into this accelerator and start
colliding these beams and start doing
some new physics and over the next year
they'll start raising the energy of this
accelerator to the point where well I'm
will be in a new energy regime where
which allows us to get to get
experimental data about what's happening
at higher energy which also quote which
corresponds to what's happening at
shorter and shorter distances to
to see what's happening a shortage or
distances in some sense you need to use
shorter and shorter wavelength or higher
and higher energy probes and this uh
this new accelerator you know it finally
promises some data in this new energy
range beyond what we've been able to see
so far and they're they're reasons to
believe that this new energy range is
one where that we can actually start to
get answers to some of these questions
about especially about mass about why
why do different particles have
different masses
so so so the state of the standard model
is that it is quite beautiful theory but
you um to make the whole thing work you
need a you you need to make sure that a
certain kind of a physical phenomenon
has to happen basically and one way of
saying it is that the theory has certain
symmetries and and the the lowest tenet
the lowest energy theory the lowest
energy state the vacuum of the theory
has to have non-trivial properties under
one of these symmetries it can't
normally you say a vacuum state is just
kind of complete and interesting if you
you rotate it around move it around the
vacuum state it can't nothing can happen
it's just a vacuum state but um but the
vacuum actually has to have interesting
properties under these kind of
mathematical symmetry transformations
and the so so we know that that has to
be true in order to make the theory work
and there are there many ways you can
imagine making that happen and and one
way is called the Higgs the Higgs
mechanism and so the Higgs mechanism
involves a postulating existence of some
some new fields a new kind of matter
which is this this Higgs part this this
Higgs field and and and then giving this
you did the dynamics for the making the
properties of the Higgs field such that
the fact that the in the vacuum state
the Higgs field will have this non
trivial property so you you can do that
in some sense the Higgs field is kind of
the simplest way of getting what you
want but when you do it you also you you
you you end up losing the ability to
predict all sorts of things because then
if some then there the question of why
why did why does a particle have a
certain mass just becomes well because
that's how strong its how strongly it
interacts with the Higgs field so you
it's a simplest way of making something
happen you know has to happen but it
it's a way which has a lot of things you
don't really like it's not very
satisfactory way of doing it because it
kind of of necessity then leaves open a
whole range of question and questions
which you would hope to have answers to
but you just from you
can't answer that way so one thing which
we hope to learn from the LHC is is this
Higgs mechanism or this Higgs field
really there in which case that that'll
that'll be actually somewhat of a
disappointment because it'll mean that
okay this theory kind of continues to
work and we don't we still don't know
how to answer some these questions or I
think that the much more exciting
possibility is going to be that there's
some somewhat something else causing
this phenomenon of the of the vacuum
behaving this way and and there's
something else would be you know give us
some what would be so it would be
something which would be more
interesting and will allow answers to
these questions so instead so this hole
is this name of the Higgs field and
finding the Higgs particle that's kind
of a it's an oversimplified way of
saying what we're really hoping which is
we're really hoping to understand what
is causing the vacuum to behave this way
and and we have good reason there's kind
of a number in the theory which kind of
says how big this phenomenon going on in
the vacuum is and and what the size of
it is and the size is exactly the size
that this this accelerator should
finally be able to probe so there it's
not um there's a very good reason to
believe that this is the right machine
to kind of start answering some of these
questions
the real problem is that the ways that
we in it that there are various ways a
lot of people study a lot of other
alternatives to the Higgs field which M
the problem is that they're all fairly
complicated and none of them they all
have as bad or even worse problem is in
the Higgs field so David they've all so
none of them are convincing we don't
have a convincing alternative to it
and and I don't either I guess I mean
the one about all I can say about that
is that the there I'm very interested in
some of the kind of mathematical parts
of the theory that we don't understand
and some of the kind of deep
mathematical structure that we don't
understand and are in these theories and
part of what we don't understand in
these theories actually is you know is
related to this problem of the vacuum of
this behavior of the vacuum so I mean in
in my ideal world the the the it would
turn out that there's there's there
something that we there's something
still to be learned about the
mathematical structure of these theories
which it would would in the end you know
explain this this Higgs this Higgs
phenomenon is this problem with the
vacuum but but I mean I I wish I knew
how to do that but I certainly don't
have a and has a very vague reason to
believe it there that's an interesting
thing to look at but but I certainly
don't have an answer to it and I think
if I had to assign probabilities to it
what I would guess is that the I'd say
there's about a 50% chance the LHC will
actually see an actual Higgs particle
and there will be there is some kind of
Higgs field and that this is going to be
kind of depressing for us because it
means well whatever there is this field
there's it's it's working like this and
the answer these questions we would like
answers to are you'd have to go to even
higher energies or smaller distances to
understand them and or there's there's I
think there's a 50% probability will
find that we won't see a Higgs particle
or at least on a Higgs particle the kind
that that you see in the simplest model
and then that would and that will
actually give us clues as to what's
really going on and that will be a much
more exciting this time but I don't know
which is going to happen
there's no reason the UM the general
problem with particle physics is that
these questions we're asking are at you
know they're having at such high energy
scales or such short distances that it's
um it's very hard to see how to do
anything very practical with this I mean
anything like these particles we're
talking about you know how often have
have lifetimes which are you know 10 to
the minus 20 seconds or I mean they're
they're they're they're just if you
produce a Higgs particle it's gonna be
so short-lived it's incredibly difficult
to even see any evidence of the thing
it's not something you can be able to go
out and use these Higgs particles to
carry around and do something with them
on the other hand I mean you don't
really know what you're gonna find it if
you do find especially if you find
something but I guess I I could say it
this way if you do just find this Higgs
particle in just the SIG's field it's
very hard to did to me to do anything
really practical with that if you if you
find some completely new understanding
of this theory then who knows I mean you
can conjecture a come up with all sorts
of models you can come up with models in
which there's kind of new heavy
long-lived particles which you could
then imagine doing things with but um I
think it is probably pretty a good bet
that with it with in the near future
this is not really a big be practical
this is really a matter of just trying
to understand the world better or not
not not something it's not in a way but
not in a way that's particularly gonna
be useful for for doing anything too
practical it's gonna affect people
anytime soon
I mean some of some of that is because
people one of the alternatives to this
is this Higgs mechanism is it and people
started studying so that says some
models in which well to go back a little
bit I mean one thing about string theory
is string theory to make string theory
work you have to have extra dimensions
you have to have more than the three
space and one-time dimensions and that
then that's kind of in some sense the
main problem was that with string theory
that you have to you have to have like
five least five extra dimensions I start
sorry six extra dimensions and the the
predictions of theory and being able to
produce it for anything depend upon
what's happening these six extra
dimensions and that's no one has ever
initially the hope was that there was a
fairly small number of consistent ways
of dealing these extra dimensions and
that would you know it make this a
predictive theory but it's turned out
there's just too much you can do and you
can kind of get anything you want by
having these extra dimensions do
different things and so what one thing
as part of this one thing that people
studied was models in which that these
extra mentions are actually of exactly
the right size that the LHC should start
seeing evidence of these extra
dimensions and and and producing black
holes because it because of these extra
dimensions and that's a um there's just
never really been a reason to believe
that these extra dimensions would we'd
see no evidence of them at our best
accelerators now when we go up by a
factor of seven in energy and all of a
sudden all these extra benches would
appear there's just there's absolutely
no reason for that to be to happen it's
you can make speculative models which it
happens but but there first of all then
anyway so that there's there's really
kind no mode no good motivation for
these models and for them to happen and
no evidence for them and then even if
they were to exist than they did happen
any such black holes would kind of
immediately it'd become completely
unstable and when it would just
immediately decay into something else so
you wouldn't
you're not gonna produce a dangerous
black hole that way but but but but the
first kind of I think what caused all
this trouble is that people kind of
wanted to
to promote these extra dimensional
models even though there was no good
motivation for them and so they promoted
them by saying well in principle you
know since we don't know what happens at
higher energies they'll you see maybe
I've identities extra mentions will show
up but there's no good reason for that
so but once people started promoting the
idea of these extra dimensions might
show up then people that well if they
show up then maybe they'll be black
holes and it was kind of speculation on
top of speculation I have a speculation
but it's all it's all suffrage there's
hasn't it has no reason to believe and
any such thing could it could possibly
be true
I mean that thing at most
whole subject is is something that
probably quickly gets very technical but
but there's a there's some there's
there's an area of mathematics which is
known as representation theory and from
one way of thinking and it is thinking
about it is in terms of what are what
physicists often call symmetries so so
for instance one of the basic facts
about the laws of nature is that they're
there they're symmetric laws of nature
are the same at you know if you move if
you move in any direction or you move in
time back and forth the laws of physics
don't change if you rotate things around
and three dimensions laws of physics
don't change and so so these so-called
symmetries and and these these
symmetries have very important physical
implications so friends the fact that
the laws of physics don't change as if
you change your if you move in time has
the physical implication that there's
this thing called energy and energy is
conserved and the same thing that and
that the fact that laws of physics don't
change if you move back and forth in
different directions in space implies
that there's a something called momentum
and momentum is conserved it doesn't
change in as you move as you evolve in
time and so so these very very
fundamental facts about physics are kind
of deeply grounded in the symmetries of
of nature and so to a mathematician this
this this question is is a question well
what we call about groups and
representations of these groups so if
you go into any math department and look
at what they're doing you'll see that
you know that a lot of a lot of people
and different kinds of mathematics are
studying different structures which are
also called groups and they're often
studying what are called representations
of these groups so even people studying
num number theory kind of abstract
things about about prime numbers or
something
they're also studying groups and sort of
representation of these groups so
there's kind of a to the extent that
mathematics has a kind of unifying theme
and a unifying principle which shows up
in different areas of mathematics it's
about this redness these representations
a representation theory and the most
strake one most ANU the most tricks me
about physics almost fascinates me about
it is that if you look at quantum
mechanics
quantum mechanics initially looks like a
very odd structure it doesn't it's not
something week we have any kind
intuitive understanding of it doesn't
look like you know like what the way
we're used to thinking about physics
based on our everyday experience
but if you look at the mathematical
structure and the basic structures of
quantum mechanics they're exactly the
structures that show up in this theory
in this theory of representations so
there's a kind of a deep relation
between math and physics which is what
is surrounding this whole notion of
symmetries and representations of
symmetries so so that so that's one
thing that's always fascinated me and
then that and my own research my own
interest is is in kind of developing -
taking a lot that's been learned in
mathematics there's a lot that's been
learned in mathematics over the years
about how to think about representations
and how to construct them and how to
work with them some of it has made its
way into physics have been used in
physics and was been used in physics
since the early days of quantum
mechanics and so friends is one of the
great kind of to the extent there's a
kind of hero of this book I wrote about
this it's a mathematician called Hermann
vile who was a special who kind of was
one of the first people to understand
how klondike hanoks worked and to
understand the relation to
representations but but but anyway I
think there's still a lot to be learned
in that way and very specifically the
so-called standard model has this group
of symmetries which is called a gauge
symmetry and it's an infant eventual
group and the standard kind of physics
conjecture or understanding of the
representations of this group is that
there's is that that should not be an
interesting question there should only
be a trivial representation of this
group but anyway my gestures that
there's there's actually a much more
interesting question there and uh and
pursuing that you can pursuing this
question of how do you deal with the
would they get the gauge symmetry of
this theory and in terms of using ideas
from representation theory that are um
that are more well known in mathematics
that haven't been used in physics before
that you can actually get somewhere so
that's maybe a bit too technical but
that's about as good as I can do with
hard to say there's some I'm gonna prove
no there's a lot of mean the problem
with yeah elegance is actually an
interesting question maybe to say what
it what is it what is elegance and what
is it what is beauty I guess so one
thing the one thing that's come up even
within this this the string theory um
issue is this question or you know is
this a beautiful idea or a beautiful
theory so so my colleague Brian Greene
has written a very very good book about
this called the elegant universe and so
he's um and so and we didn't within
within physics this is our I mean we're
we're often very struck by some of these
basic ideas are we would like to our
very striking and that we act in a way
which we like to describe as being
elegant or beautiful but um the problem
with with those that terminology
especially the terminology of beauty is
that beauty means a lot of different
things to a lot of different people a
lot of different ways in which things
can be beautiful but this really has a
very specific meaning and and which is
more along the lines of elegans which is
that we say that an idea is beautiful or
elegant in mathematics or physics if you
know a very simple principle a very
simple idea or a simple set of ideas
turns out to be very powerful and and
you know leads to all sorts of
unexpected structure and unexpected
predictions and I think you know maybe
the what I find is is the most beautiful
most elegant think about this whole
subject is a little bit what I was
trying to explain earlier if for
instance this idea maybe just to say
this idea that the fact that the laws of
physics are the same as you as you move
in time means that has very unexpected
significance it means that there there
is this thing called energy and you can
associate a number of called energy to
us to two physical systems and it's not
going to change it as you as time
evolves so the I mean that's actually
the so in classical physics that's
actually there that that's a theorem
called annoy others theorem after a
method called let me neither
so so so they're there it's a little bit
of a slight lead on trivial theorem and
that's certainly a a beautiful theorem
what what fascinates me more is that in
quantum mechanics
norther standard isn't even a theorem
it's just kind of it's just implicit in
the definition just the way you set
things up it just is automatically true
so it's a yeah anyway there there's the
theorem and a proof in classical physics
and then you you start to think about
quantum mechanics and you think about it
and then it's just kind of automatically
true there's not even a theorem anymore
and it's a that's just beautiful
well I think I mean any kind of thing
that human beings do there's certain
politics to it and certain academic
politics and policy wouldn't field so
but um but mathematics is actually a
relatively healthy field these days I
mean people are you know are are making
making good progress in a lot of
different different ways and it's it's
also so so anyway I've kind of lived
part of my professional life and
mathematics and part in physics and and
and one thing to say about mathematics
is it's uh I think it can have its
problems but but it actually hasn't seen
a it hasn't seen a lot of the problems
of other sciences and politically partly
probably also the wonderful thing about
mathematics assistance so much of it
what people are doing is completely
useless nobody nobody kind of in the
outside world really cares very much you
don't really have you don't have kind of
a right and left and people getting in
you know kind of ideology coming in
because there isn't any
it just doesn't actually connect up to
the kinds of things that people who work
you know worry about ideologically
worried about so in most of mathematics
it doesn't doesn't tell you I think one
way or another about global warming or
about you know health care or about any
other number of things you might care
about so so what's the mathematics is
immune to a lot of exterior
real world politics because of that and
the academic Pollak so the manera but um
I think it's actually less than a lot of
fields I out one of my colleagues likes
to say that mathematics is the he thinks
that about the only subject that he
knows of in academia or in the real
world where if two people disagree about
something if people are studying some
mathematical object then there's there
supposed to be a proof and they disagree
about whether this proof works or not
they will you know go into a room sit
down and talk about it and fairly
quickly or at the end of the day one of
them will admit they're wrong and he
says you know that's the problem the
laptop news is this just doesn't happen
whereas mathematics this is just happens
all the time and so the people um there
is this notion of logic and proof and
rigor which we can all allows us to kind
of all stay on one track
physics is um well things they have
physics first of all fit physics is a
very complicated subject with many many
different things the string theory and
particle physics are only a small part
of physics I want to talk about physics
and I talk about them and the problems
of those subjects it's really a problems
of a very small you know one discipline
and one subfield of physics and a lot of
physicists people are kind of happily
going on and doing their science and
quite successfully and it has nothing to
do with and they get very very annoyed
when they hear people going on about the
problems of string theory as if that's
some big problem for physics because
it's not their problem string theory and
particle physics you know it suffers I
think a lot from that from this business
of being from its own success from not
having any not it nobody kind of it kind
of has it has been able to come up with
any really good idea as to make positive
progress just because there's been no
experimental evidence to give you a clue
as to which direction to go and and that
the subject is I think traditionally
been very connected often in at least
from mathematicians point of you in a
very faddish way that everybody all the
smart people the subject the idea was
was it would all kind of jump at the
same problem and all try and work in the
same problem very often because the
subject was driven by experiment and you
know somebody would go out and turn on a
new accelerator like the LHC at higher
energy and this is certainly gonna
happen next year if the LHC you see
something unexpected everyone in the
whole field is going to be trying to
explain that one thing and so you have a
very kind of a little bit of kind of
fascist sociology that everybody is
trying to do do the same thing at the
same time or as in other fields like
mathematics people kind of spread out
and develop extra their expertise and
work on different things so part of the
problem of the the politics of particle
theory and has been that you have people
used to the idea that well you should
look around and see what these smart
people are working on and I should work
on the same thing as them and so you've
got you know all these people kind of
trying to do this and so string theory
then got identified back in 84 as being
the hot topic and for a lot of reasons
partly and probably because it was an
intriguing idea but
but partly also because one of the
there's one of the great geniuses of our
subject that Edward Witten who's a steel
fantastic genius has done these amazing
things and you know he got very
interested in it and he started
promoting idea that this is a very
promising idea and so everyone kind of
jumped jumped on it and and and my
initial reaction at that time that was I
was just getting out of graduate school
at that time and you know partly the way
I work the way I think III wasn't so
interesting idea of try and do it same
thing as everybody else I would prefer
to work on something a bit different and
partly also Minh say me that you know it
wasn't that this was obviously a good
idea it might be a good idea might not
but but there were obvious problems with
it from the beginning and so anyway so
starting any idea before everybody
started working on this and I think my
reaction to it was well you know that's
great that they're doing this and what's
going to happen is what normally happens
in the subject is that after six months
or a year or two years people will see
whether it's a good idea or not and you
know you and if it's not a good idea
they'll move on and the really peculiar
thing that happened here was that you
know 25 years later this is still
there's still a lot of people doing this
I mean it really kind of caught fire and
even without succeeding it still kind of
developed into this whole into this huge
subject and it kind of in some sense
kind of achieved some kind of critical
mass and more and more people were
working on it and working on it for so
long that people ended up kind of
devoting their careers to it and did
it's a very very difficult and a very
complicated subject and it it requires
quite a lot of time just to even get to
the point of understanding what's going
on so you had lots of more and more
people working on this investing more
and more of their time and their careers
and their lives into it and and I think
it really got to the enforcement point
that people were kind of unwilling to
the kind of admit that this wasn't
working and it's a natural human
reaction to an idea of you're fond of
you put a lot into it it's kind of hard
to get to to get you to admit often well
maybe this is
work and and then this was kind of
happening very much in spades in this
story I think it's been very hard to get
people to name it admit that this this
is something it hasn't worked out
so there's actually kind of two there
maybe I could kind of two things that
one is the blog I also have wrote this
book and so the anyway for firm for many
years I was I wasn't very happy with
what was going on there and I was kind
of observing it okay this is becoming
more and more problematic there's this
you know not only are people kind of not
admitting that this isn't working out
but you know there's there's this whole
that you know there's a lot of kind of
public promotion of the subject and and
it's a very difficult complicated
subject a lot of people don't don't
understand it and so it's this is really
not a healthy situations that someone
should kind of you know could have
clearly explained to larger community of
physicists and also to non physicists
exactly what the situation is here and
and so I wrote an article about this and
then I finally wrote this book and it
took a while to get the book published
that's a long and interesting story but
but then while after I guess since after
after the book was written I also
started it's hard to see there are a
couple other physicists what started
blogs and I thought well this isn't
interesting interesting thing to try to
do and I can both talk about you know
these issues related to string theory
and things which I was trying to get out
through the book but also kind of follow
it in a day to day basis and also just
kind of write about whatever I'm
interested in so the the blog I I guess
I don't worry a lot about who about the
about the audience for it it's kind of
written because I realized it's very
much just really just kind of whatever
whatever I would like to read so I'm
gonna read I'm kind of writing whatever
I would like to read stuff this so if
there's somebody out there exactly like
me they much find this really
fascinating and if there's something
quite different they find it not at all
interesting and so but because of that
it's some the kinds of things in the
blog are often you know if I if I learn
something or something new interesting
going on and even in pure mathematics
I'll be writing about that or pretty
much anything going on in between
mathematics and physics
I'll be writing about that writing a lot
about the LHC and but and also just
about whatever is going on in this
controversy over string theory and it um
it's kind of memorial that this my book
came out and there was at the same time
there's a book by another physicist with
a similar point of view to mind
came out so that that caused a lot of
controversies with a lot of reviews and
a lot of argument going on on these
blogs and a lot of people refer to this
as the string Wars and so the there's
this free for for a year or two there
there was a kind of a very interesting
if you're interesting this kind of thing
there's an interesting warfare in terms
of blog postings and comments going on
on my site and various others and that
was a ultra little that would lead to
all sorts of strange things
some I don't mean III often learn you
know interesting things from common you
know so so now that the blog is fairly
well known so you know people will write
in comments oh I've logged often telling
me about something I hadn't heard about
or new button you don't know about and
that that's very interesting in order
all they'll often send it to me
privately by email saying you know hey
you might be interested in this and so I
get a lot of that and learn a lot that
way
oh one interesting I thought amusing
like the whole string theory thing
discussion was that it's a it really is
it's an incredibly complex and difficult
subject and so it's really hard to
overemphasize how it's a something that
really nobody understands very well and
even the people who are the most experts
at it are you know and it's amazing
experience of having a conversation with
some Nobel Prize winners who people are
thought of as the the brightest people
this field and asking them what they
think in string theory and they'll say
no I don't know I don't really
understand what's going on I want to
comment on it and it's just I'm baffled
by it so one interesting thing about the
some of these discussions in the blog
was I found one way to figure out
exactly what's going on in in string
theory and whether you know something is
really a problem or or not is to just
put up my understanding of it you know
in a blog post here in the comment or
whatever and then fairly quickly you
would find that either you know either I
was wrong and there there was some
reason that this actually made sense
even though I thought it didn't and this
would I would I would quickly often
abusively he explained me what an idiot
I was and why this was you know here's
the here's the answer what you really
should have known or and then then I
found out that okay I learned something
or or or often I would found out that if
I was right if there really was a
problem here the answer I would get
would often be just this abuse of oh you
know you're a complete jerk and you're
moron and but but no no no scientific
answer to the scientific question so
that was one that was actually an
interesting way to kind of see exactly
what the state of research and the
subject was by kind of probing it and
trying to and and getting that kind of
response from some of the more hostile
people and
in subject
I mean it's mostly a positive thing I
mean one thing to say about the one of
the main problems with the blog's one
most annoying thing about the blog's is
especially if a lot of people are
reading it you're really in a situation
where other there's a small number of
people who really understand this and
know what's going on and have something
really sensible to say about it there's
a very large number of people who have
some kind of interest in it and you know
have the time and energy to sit there
and write uninformed things on your blog
and and kind of just says so so I
actually did I think I'd like some vlogs
I actually delete a lot of the comments
submitted to my blog and try to keep the
noise level down and so that's the most
probably the most discouraging thing
about the whole experience it's just
this the number of people out there who
kind of want to go on about this nagi
about this but don't know what they're
talking about and and and and want to
kind of fill the internet and all
information sources they get their hands
on with kind of under form nonsense so
there's a lot of that but the little bit
but just the kind of discussion of the
subject and of its problems which I
think went on in these blogs and which
are in which you know if you're
interested you can now have information
could go and see and read I don't think
there's really any other format you know
it's an amazing format for that there's
really no other way that you know that
discussion could it could be held in
that way and and and also the internet
just provides this kind of amazing
access to all information of a sort
which is just totally unlike anything
we've had before you can you know just
Google some term and immediately have
access to all sorts of often high-level
discussions of the subject and um I
think the one well it's actually made
some of the fattest nosov particle
Theory actually a bit worse in the sense
that one thing that used to kind of slow
down fads was just the how long it took
to communicate them to people I mean you
know the certain prominent people might
have started working on some idea at
Princeton or Harvard but it would take a
while for that news of that and
understanding of what these people were
doing to filter out to the rest of the
community and people wanted to kind of
jump on it and pursue it in a faddish
way it would take them well to even find
out
whereas now everybody is kind of every
night there's a new set of pre prints
coming out in the preprint server and
people log again and looking at these
and the minute that somebody has some
new thing which is becoming a kind of
fetish thing to work on everybody
throughout the world has it at exactly
the same time when their desktop and can
start thinking about it and working on
it and so it kind of makes that even
more so than it used to be